Franchement, les timides, je sais
qu'ils ne sont pas bien dans leur peau
et qu'ils ne font pas exprès,
c'est pas de leur faute, tout ça.
Mais comment ils font, en soirée,
pour pas sortir un seul mot, quoi ?
Enfin, je ne sais pas,
ça ne va pas les tuer de parler !
[♪ musique ♪]
Hé, je peux avoir une grenadine ?
[pan]
En plus, quand ils se retrouvent le lendemain
entre potes timides, à la fac ou au travail,
qu'est-ce qu'ils peuvent bien se raconter
de leurs soirées de la veille ?
Alors, c'était comment ta soirée hier ?
Ben, je suis resté assis sur une chaise
toute la soirée et j'ai rien dit du tout.
Oh putain, énorme !
'Tain, j'aurais trop voulu y être !
Non, mais c'est vrai, ils ne sont
pas méchants, les timides, mais moi,
quand j'essaie d'engager
la conversation avec eux,
ils ont la faculté de me mettre
relativement mal à l'aise.
Alors toi, qu'est-ce que
tu fais dans la vie ?
Euh, moi, je fais de la biologie.
Ah, OK. Donc tu dois bien connaître
le corps humain, les trucs comme ça ?
Heu, non.
Pas spécialement.
Sinon, qu'est-ce que tu écoutes
comme style de musique ?
Il y a juste une règle
qu'il ne faut jamais transgresser :
ne jamais faire boire
de l'alcool à un timide !
Jamais !
Parce qu'un mec normal,
quand il boit de l'alcool, il est un peu foufou.
Mais un timide, quand il boit,
le mec, il se transforme !
Ouais, je suis plus timide !
Et en plus, je suis trop pas bourré, sérieux !
Les timides, quand ils boivent de l'alcool,
ils se transforment en dark timides.
Toi, t'es bourré, mais lui,
c'est le mec le plus bourré du monde !
Hé, les mecs,
je suis pété !
On dirait que tout ce qu'il a contenu
en lui pendant des années a rien dire,
il a décidé de donner maintenant à la soirée.
Il donne tout, le gars !
Ah, franchement, j'avais besoin de le faire,
je me sens trop bien, les mecs ! Un whisky, s'il te plaît !
Il fait chier les gens,
il danse comme un taré sur la piste,
il n'a plus de limite !
Le mec, il parle
à tous les inconnus dans la rue.
Je m'en bats les couilles,
je suis plus timide !
Aaaahhh !
Je suis plus timide !
Faux !
Non mais, les dark timides,
ils sont juste ingérables.
Et passé une certaine heure,
tu sais pas pourquoi,
mais le mec qui est, à la base, ton pote,
veut te péter la gueule. Ça, c'est génial !
Ha ha, pas mal !
>> Ça, c'est mon gâteau, OK ?
>> Heu, ben, je l'avais pris dans le paquet, là...
>> Tu veux qu'on se tape ?
Non, non, ça va, je...
mais non merci.
Ouais, c'est ça, fais-moi ton petit regard de fourbe.
Je te démonte, moi, je suis un bonhomme !
Bon, OK, tu l'auras voulu !
[♪ musique ♪]
Cergy, attaque éclair !
[bruit d'explosion]
Aaaaahhhh !
Bien joué, Cergy !
[tope-là]
Vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux
sur la page Facebook "Norman fait des vidéos".
Franchement, ça fait super plaisir !
[bips]
Vous êtes vraiment supers !
[♪ musique ♪]